Hey everyone, it's Mike from Motorflows
and welcome back to my channel. You
know, it's a crazy market uh that we're
in right now. You see this market is
just ripping. Here's a bar. This is a
one minute mees chart. Um I can't even
get the footprint to show the actual uh
volume because the market uh just ripped
from well the bar opened at what 49 and
ripped all the way up to uh
527 and a quarter in one minute. So,
obviously there's a lot of uh talk going
on, but you know, the whole point of
this video is a question I've been
getting a lot lately is how to trade
Trump's tariffs, right? That, you know,
it's really a trade war um that's going
on uh around the world.
And the the easy answer is you don't,
right? There's there's no shame in
sitting on the sidelines, right? Because
you get caught off sides in in one of
these moves as you just see right here.
Um is the next bar just ripped from you
know we opened up at 81 and a half sold
all the way down to
24 you know that's you know we just sell
off uh 50 50 handles then we just rip
from you know from that low area I mean
I'll just call it 30 all the 5130 all
the way up to
5280 almost close to 150 points um you
know so again you know if you're on the
right side that's great. If you're on
the wrong side, you're going to get
stopped
out. I don't know, man. Pretty bad. And,
you know, pretty quick. And again, it's
one of these things where if you don't
have to trade this market, don't trade
it, right? And that being said is, well,
how do you know, you know, you shouldn't
be involved in a market like this? Well,
the easy answer is you look at the VIX,
right? You come into the day, you see
where VIX is trading. I mean, you should
have an idea already if if you've been
involved in these markets, you know, you
you should be following the VIX anyway.
Um, just type in VIX index and and
you'll get this little nice little
chart. You know, anywhere up near 50,
not good. Um, you know, ideally we
should be uh, you know, around 20 or or
below
20s is sort of normal. Um, in the teens
is is kind of uh, in my opinion kind of
normal. Um if if you look here, you
know, five years, you know, 12, you
know, 2023, we're we're just in the in
the teens. Um this goes back 20, you
know, during COVID, we're again back up
in the 40s. We're even above some of
those levels from 2020. You know, we're
at at 49. Just because uh VIX is green
doesn't mean it's a good thing, right?
Normally in stocks, you know, we're so
used to looking at
uh green and thinking that's good, but
you know, when VIX is green, that means
uh there's a lot of volatility in that
market. So, um you know, you there's no
uh nobody putting a gun to your head
saying you have to trade this market.
So, what can you trade uh when when VIX
is that high? Um well, the problem
is what we got going on with this uh
trade war around the world is you also
have issues in the bond markets, right?
the basis trades are starting to be
unwound. Um you know I'll be I won't be
surprised to to hear if there's
uh you know some hedge funds going
under. You know who knows maybe they're
going to want some government bailout.
You know I think you know many of you
traders are too young. You probably some
of you probably weren't even born during
the the uh long-term
capital
crash back in the back in the 90s. Um,
normally I'd say, hey, you know, bonds
are a nice market, but since we're in
this very interest rate sensitive
market, you can see here again, you
know, bonds are, you know, one, this is
1132. My goodness, all the way up to
11410 in in 1 minute. Um, you know,
that's a whole basis point there. It's
just uh insane, right? Normally bonds on
a one minute chart would move like this.
You know, maybe you get the occasional
bar that moves four ticks, five ticks,
but most of the times bonds on a one
minute chart would just move, you know,
bid in the offer basically. You know,
another example, 10
years. Okay, 10 years would move even
slower than um the ZB, right? The the
30-year bond.
And yeah, normally it if you look at the
the the tens, it's can be uh like
watching paint dry. Basically, you're
trading the bid, the offer. Um you know,
maybe a tick or two above it or below
the bid and the offer. But now again
with all this volatility, the markets
are just uh sort of off the charts in
terms of uh price movements. Again, you
know, this is this is not normal what
you're looking at how bonds are are this
is 10 years how they are trading. Again,
most of the time it's it's just similar
to how it was trading uh sort of
earlier. Okay, but uh so what other
markets can you look at? Well, if you
really want a slowmoving market, you
know, I I would suggest corn. Okay,
nothing wrong with corn. I mean, we all
got to eat, right? So, corn is uh is an
interesting market. you do see a little
bit of ripple effect coming into this
corn market, you know, as equities uh
spiked
up. I I haven't looked at Twitter yet
because I'm recording right now, but I
don't know, maybe something happened
with uh China and the tariffs. Maybe
someone blinked and backed off. But corn
is a nice market for trading. You know,
you could look at it on, let me see
here. You know, I do believe on corn. I
I do like to use uh four range chart
because it is a slower moving market and
by using a rangebased chart I think it's
it's good for you to uh capture the
movements right because on slower moving
markets you don't want to be constrained
by time in the sense of okay I'm looking
at a one minute chart and exactly after
1 minute it forms a new bar whereas a uh
rangebased chart obviously is based on
price movement and there's a lot of nice
things that you can see on a rangebased
chart in the corn. It's moving nicely.
You're not getting these big whips saws
that you're seeing in in equities that's
that's going
to blow up your account, you know. But
that being said, you know, there are
times again, you you do want to be
attuned to things that can move the
markets. If you're trading any sort of
agricultural market, you got to be aware
of um the WASDY report when it comes
out. you. But if you look at a, you
know, look at a trading calendar, it
will be on there. But the same thing
that I would normally be looking at on a
um E- mini chart, MEES chart, bond
chart, I would look at in the corn, it
trades very good volume. Even on the
four range chart, you can see 2,900,
1100, sorry, 1,00 1,00 2,600, 24. So
there's enough information that you can
make good trading decisions, right? What
would I look at? I would look at the
value areas. I would look at prominent
point of controls. Let's just pull up
the settings here really
quick.
Um I would not use level three,
but you know, you can see in here you
could even, you know, I don't have
stacked imbalances on, but I I could
even turn that on. Now, again, on a
four-range chart, you might not get many
stacked imbalances, but still, it's
always good to have on. I do have
stopping volume. it set
uh set quite high at uh at
50. I'll make the opacity 50 so it
stands out a bit more from um prominent
point of
controls.
Okay. So I can see here right prominent
point of control prominent point of
control got stopping volume coming in
there. Prominent point of control
stopping volume. Same thing here. Same
thing here. Prominent point of control
was stopping volume plus an abandoned
value area. You can see the market had a
nice uh rally
there. Now again, you know, sort of one
of the things you do have to understand
with uh commodity markets is it can go
limit up or limit down. And it doesn't
happen very often. So unlike you know
equity indices that have circuit
breakers, um commodity markets don't.
they have daily price limits. Okay, so
like cattle
futures
that hit the price limits last week. Let
me just change this to a one minute
chart.
Um, so again, you know, yeah, the market
had some nice movement when so it's got
to be something with the trade wars with
the tariffs that came out on Twitter. I
I again I I haven't had a chance to take
a look but last week I believe it was on
Friday. You see this is a market that
went limit down. So you can see market
selling off selling off then it hits the
limit. Boom. This was the limit 198
uh 20 offer. So it's limit offer. And
and what that means is you know people
think that when the market hits limit
down or limit up it stops trading. No
the market's still open in this case. So
you can't sell below this limit price.
You can join the
offer or you can buy the offer. So
again, you know, you can see people come
in here. It came off limit. You know,
there's a couple times it came off limit
here. People are they're more than
happy, more than willing. I say more
than willing, but people can buy all
they want. Whatever's on the not say all
they want, but whatever's on the offer,
sort of the
pool. But trading is not stopped.
People, you know, I see a lot of
misinformation. And they think that when
the market is limit down, trading stops.
No. In
commodities, the market's still open,
but you can't sell anything. You could
join the offer, but unless someone comes
in to buy it, you're not going to get
filled. Then the market will close.
Okay? So then it closed and then the
next day it reopened and you see the big
drop here. All right? So it continued
lower. All right? And then it started to
rally back up um and eventually took out
that level that we were at uh right
here. All right, we came back the next
day and and and reached it. But
again, you know, that that's not every
commodity market and and that's the
thing. You still got to be aware of
what's going on in the world. Obviously,
like when Russia invaded
Ukraine, wheat went limit up for a
couple of
days. That happens in commodity markets.
All right? But if you're a day trader,
you know, there's a lot of uh there's a
lot of good markets that you could also
be
trading beyond just equity indices.
People say, well, why why would you want
to trade something like this? Well, it's
a good market to, you know, sort
of understand the dynamics of supply and
demand and how they show up in the order
flow. you know where the heavy volume is
coming in. Um I crude here at these
levels 57 bucks but just sort of going
back right normally this is how the
market looks right with the normal bars
like
this. So you there's not much difference
when you're looking at say crude oil in
terms of how the order flow is trading
then whether you're looking at bonds or
whether you're looking at cattle or you
know wheat or soybeans. Soybeans
probably what time is it? It's 12:30.
Beans are still open. Um, let's take a
look at uh at beans. All right. So, we
got some nice movement there as well.
So, you know, all these markets, they're
all available. There's there's other
markets besides the equity indices. You
don't need to be putting yourself behind
the eightball and blowing up your
account when there's other markets that
you can trade. All right. So anyway, you
know, if you want my opinion on on how
to trade these uh quote Trump markets
is stay away
from the markets that are going to have
the most immediate impact, the hardest
hit, where if Trump sneezes, the
market's going to move uh 30 points,
right? Stay away from those that are
that are so sensitive. go with the other
markets that are basically going to
have, you know, sort of normal trading.
All right, so I hope that helps some of
you guys. It may not help many of you,
but there are a few out there that I
know are struggling trying to trade uh
the stock indices just because it's
yeah, you get these rip your face off uh
moves, you know, that
that while I like to think that
uh there I mean, well, right now we just
saw sort of the rip your face off move
uh take
place in the uh here. Let's pull up this
chart. This is sort of the the rip your
face off move where it rallied uh two
200 points in a few minutes. Well,
but you got to realize like with co if
you remember, right? Just co it's not
that long ago. It's only uh 5 years ago,
but markets were selling off every oh
it's the end of the world. You know,
crude was trading at a negative uh
number for a little while and then what
happened? all the markets freaking
rallied like a
mofo because when things seem the worst
sometimes that's the best time to buy
you know problem is you don't know when
the bottom's coming in right it's it
sounds easy that we're going to have a
meltup because if this trade war gets
resolved somehow what's going to happen
with the market it's going to go back up
to those levels that we were at um not
too long ago and you see how here we're
just ripped 200 points over 200 points
points in just a few minutes. Okay. So,
you
know, the hard part is just figuring out
when to buy. Obviously, you're going to
have to sit through some volatility. I
mean, if if you bought here at
5080, you know, not many of us can hold
from 5080 all the way down to 4980,
okay? Um to catch that move. So, part of
the the the whole point is to be uh be
nimble, be ready for that rip your face
off move. How would I trade it? I don't
know. I'd probably just put stuff behind
at new highs. Um catch those breakouts
because honestly, if if we're going to
have a rip your face off
move, we're going to be making new
highs. All right? So, you do want to
catch catch them. Anyway, guys, I'm
starting to just rant here about random
things. So, if you like my videos, be
sure to subscribe to the channel, hit
that notification bell, and I'll see you
guys later. Take care.